lot of steak and folks there are we got
eight A-list celebs good pressure by
Josh Green Oh Mark Jones oh boy him and
Austin Reeves bumping their gums a
little bit and a technical foul is going
to go against Josh Green I think it
might be double check it's going to be a
double yeah
don't don't fool yourself some Rancor
and bitterness coming from the sidelines
Doris I said earlier it feels like April
almost playoff time look at this big
time implications I like the non-call
I'm gonna say it right now and Josh
Green gonna chirp a little bit and
Austin Reeves now listen this guy plays
with a chip on his shoulder and if he
doesn't he ain't in the league
he thinks everybody underestimates him I
love the non-call he's frustrated by it
as you would say Josh gonna bump his
guns
come on I'm here I'm here for the drunk
yeah yeah I like it all part of the
story
yeah we do have double technicals
which is the ultimate bailout call but
it's the NBA world that we live in I'm
fine with it
but hey
underscored by the fact that Josh Green
was playing some pretty good defense you
mentioned that a guy with good energy
and you know he hasn't lost his spirit
because of the fact that he didn't get
the start he was a starter for a while
holiday got to start but green still
very much engaged Not only was he a
starter but his numbers as a starter
were outstanding so it takes a level of
sacrifice for him to say I'm still gonna
play my game coming off the bench
because Jason Kidd risk losing him by
not giving him the same note I think
that's about communication okay you're a
coach and Josh young enough and
team-minded enough not to let it